ситуація зграя на пружинну на поздовжні
референдуму Віталій ще до
конституційної реформи опоненти влади
вийшли на вулиці з red демонстранти біля
багата хто 53 війни вішу опозиційну
партію рук 5 жирок я голосувала за
демократичну партію з думки та
наріжте пісня 20 уроків берлусконі
настало них немає шарму гарантії ви його
версію бруска не 20 теж для mail.ru
в 5 жирок на їжу на рішення багата
це леті втратив і тисне руда політики
україни геть і старіють брехню
та довіряти у убити anki я веду шукають
референдум може правді вартий його знака
is mine в італії целюліт будуть
формованих губи ти зміїний windows
чоловіки за ради інституційних реформ
excel у дейвід кидають тире форми
ми будемо мобов чат і політичну
ситуацію олег всі ви хоче з ти мою
думка
не знаю чинар мову звучать і наївно то
оптимістично їжу цього за ще глибиною
душі і піти вкрай якщо назвати чайні
правда не змінені так а військове взуття
Скільки такому виглядають хочеш і прем'єру
проти програмери for more and cis
зростання і в міру того як проблемою
Україні стоїть деталі найсерйознішим і
економіка слабко ревінь би зрубати ті
високої особи його серед молодих це
літера державний барах деталі сру стая
вінджа більше 2 3 йоні в євро курчати над
130 сотки ввп україни під потрібному
удару за знала і банківська система
найбільше постраждав монтепаски 3
солідні великі банки в італії venmo
покриті 28 мільярдів євро збут ким су
хен і батога банкрутства а по переходу по
державне управління